how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
guess in dark fears immortality does our
fear of death prevent us from fully
living yes what's the end yes but also
I'm a deaf advocate and a death activist
and I am Pro deaf and I would happily
like to say the species died and died
out I think we have destroyed enough
other species I think we had our chance
we [ __ ] it up I think that humans as
they exist today and now are simply
repeating the same anthropocentric
destructive patterns and it's no good
and so my big question as a response
would be why are we scared of death what
do we think is so valuable and precious
and important about our own
individuality that it has to keep going
forever
what kind of pathological hubris does
that involve and what would happen if we
decided to decelerate the human
ownership of the earth and start to open
up the world to the possibility of other
organisms we have seen the cessation of
so many species at our hands why is it
that we have such human exceptionalism
for our own species is it really that
valuable because I'm not seeing a lot of
benefit I'm not seeing you know people
many people but also non-human organisms
really jumping for joy at the idea of
humans living forever and I also think
that on a very sort of intimate level
death is the one thing that we all have
in common and it doesn't matter now
people might disagree with me it doesn't
matter how much money or how much
knowledge you have right now at this
point we're all gonna die
and that is the one thing that reduces
us all to the fact that we are simply
material beings and for many people
especially people in pain or in people
who don't want to live anymore the
ownership of their life is proven to
them as a fallacy because they are made
aware of the fact that under our current
government they don't own their death
and so I think we've got this macro idea
on one side that I am Pro human
extinction and anti-natal Astana much
more intimate level on our day to day
living we don't own our deaths and that
shows that we don't own our lives and I
think that in order to really understand
a sense of agency the ownership of death
should be part of the ownership of our
life so and there you have it our life
isn't really particularly valuable and
why should we cherish this in an
egotistical way why would you want to
extend it so I like to kind of agree
with the last part you said I think we
should own our deaths and totally
disagree with the first part otherwise
this would be a rather boring
conversation but we're gonna have some
interesting agreements and disagreement
here so I would start off by saying
right now I feel my life worth living
it's really really enjoyable and you
might argue that actually others the
reason you feel that it's really
enjoyable and probably some settings of
dopamine neurons in your brain we can
even list some of your netic variants
and some of the connections causing that
that doesn't change that I'm feeling
really good right now and most people I
think feel good not only everybody and
not always and that is something we
actually need it to handle that is also
why we should be able to own our lives
and actually try to make them better and
I do think that on net all living beings
want to live that is unfortunately
unfortunately what we have evolved to do
the living being is that aimed at
extinction well they didn't live mad
many descendants so for good until we
are the kind of stuff the entire
biosphere right now that tries to keep
on going and that leads to very
interesting thing that we are kind of a
smartest port advisor right now which I
completely admit doesn't mean there
smart we don't really know what we're
doing and we're messing up things in a
very bad way in a lot of ways but we
also are aware that we're messing things
up and we can try to change that so my
vision of a future would be as some of
you might have heard on the space panel
that we actually managed to get our act
together get off this planet to spread
life consciousness thinning talents
across the universe now if you're an
antenatal is this is absolute horror
there it's going to be so many minds and
some of them are going to be in pain and
there's going to be a lot of it across
the universe at the same time I do
actually think that we should recognize
that in the long run of course the
entropy always wins we right now in this
urn a beautiful spring of a universe
it's long it's just been around for
thirty billion years stars are going to
be shining in a trillion years then
we're going to go out but the universe
is going to keep on going for about a
googol years before essentially all
force of history ends when the last
black hole evaporates you might probably
get life like things going on for at
least ten to the thirty six years before
this matter starts decaying I think
there's a potential for an enormous the
great future that has enormous a
positive value and this is partially
because I don't think the pain and the
negative stuff outweighs the positive or
at least we can make sure that that is
positive
similarly individually yeah I do think
that viola I like my life it's not super
important doesn't the overall all our
considerations and I'm aware that even
though I want to have life extension arm
signed up for crayons sooner or later I
will out even because I have an accident
or because I change into something else
again sufficient life extension is
equivalent to becoming something else
even the Christian concept of going to
heaven when you start actually talking
to a few logician about how it is in
heaven you realize that you don't have a
body you don't have any negative
emotions actually an awful of a thing a
lot of the things we normally say make
us ourselves or gone and replaced by
some general be a bright light which
makes it sound like that's actually not
me going to heaven even this is usually
why people don't like talk in the fear
logicians about off the life so my
argument would be yes we're mortal even
if we manage to fix our genes and the
backers of the in cyberspace
occasionally things will go wrong and
entropy will always win but I'm not
going to kind of left in entropy just
wait and I'm gonna play hide and seek
I'm going to have rather fun with that
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in aaaggghhh